ah it's a wonderful morning the sun is
shining the birds are tweeting their
birds get off my top oh oh no you did a
little [ __ ] to work there for a
second that's that's beautiful Oh take
that ass somewhere else girl what are
you doing stop it I said stop
he's dead oh now he's don't that I love
this game what this are they multiplying
oh there god damn it
now you're pissing me off stop all right
let's go I'd oh it's so beautiful here
in my backyard
I really have the greatest taste in
sacrifice let's let all our [ __ ] up
ain't nobody touch me yeah Oh Lissie a
lesbian jeepers I don't know what you
just said but I'm glad you're back I'm
not gonna actually I'm gonna where you
guys are my I wish you could see like
you wear a lizard armor or some [ __ ]
that would be so cool nothing Lizzy what
are you doing here that's my casual deer
scat damn it
more armor for big one the armor is
amazing don't in behaving all right so
the plan for today is to make I don't
know look I look how much you need for
that that's redonkulous
I don't know how I feel about that Lizzy
stop what'd I tell you about taking a
bath you [ __ ]
oh jesus scram did he die oh you die all
right check it where then the bunny
armor okay I lit a massacre that bunny
this is so nasty I want to build a
houseboat
oh god they're coming for [ __ ] sake
let's get in the house
hold me link I'm scared
what are they hitting me through the
house hello Leslie protect me
[ __ ] you Pierre don't ever like JT me
I'm Eddie here I can see me through the
house campaign goddammit get off my turf
okay okay please do you want to die bro
do you want to die bro do you want it
that's CDs as a necklace that's adorable
where did you get it
Tiffany's [ __ ] dare you touch me
while I'm touching your boyfriend he's
dead whoa I flew like crazy
didn't you see my [ __ ] giant effigy
furniture is that [ __ ] covered in
blood why would I be covered in blood
all right listen they are [ __ ] never
[ __ ] learn let's get some more
refugees how I suppose
smack that [ __ ] I have the power of
Jesus in my hand
smack stop Darius I'll slap you twice
I'll flappy as many times as I need to
don't you dare come back to life
die die that's the weirdest thing ever
is she dead is she dead oh god he's
still there oh well she flew to space Oh
God crazy
give me that pearl necklace I mean CD
necklace alright he's dead now - any
last words well ice is too bad isn't it
now explode I need to come on his
necklace disappeared well there we go
alright now there's his head where's the
oh I love when they drop two heads it's
like they kept one in their belly or
some [ __ ]
oh maybe was pretty oh my god I should
feel bad but I
he was pretty with a full-grown man see
I had to but it only picked up one
what's up with that Lizzy I don't know
can you give me don't count my pads I
love you I love is stronger than dead
shut up this is not Titanic right Lizzy
goddamn it you're not a submarine Lizzy
your bounty you're proud today now
that's plus I have school tomorrow
Lizzy don't go to school
alright where's the other head Allah as
soon as you hold that hand everything
just [ __ ] breaks just annihilate
everything here the hand has many powers
the power of destruction and the power
of resurrection we need to chop [ __ ]
when you have a [ __ ] hand let's burn
that [ __ ] beautiful Christmas oh the
bird was on top of it
sorry little bird my wave you goodbye
what I said goodbye oh and keep working
that [ __ ] bird man I don't understand
stop it you didn't see anything bunnies
what am i doing this [ __ ] episode so
much [ __ ] is happening we need a [ __ ]
focus here ah the hand has even more
ability the power of rolling into space
there your journey ends there mister
hand
god damn be paired whoa forgot about
your power of inhalation annihilate and
I ain't no coming through coming through
alright now
you make a great lawn mower
oh good oh they were burning corpses man
up who did that
what's wrong you ran into hand stupid oh
my god it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] that I was
going to have a boat and go down the
waterfall with it maybe we can do that
that seems pretty exciting I don't know
I don't want some 1/0 here I don't I
don't want to mess with it
really got dark quick didn't he isn't
that right handy I try Pat I love you
today man can i stroke your beautiful
baby face a starfish here what the [ __ ]
so can I cut down a tree with it it's a
real question
I mean it's doing something here deeper
into the jungle we go breasts who knows
what dangers lives are hide well are
those my mushrooms oh my god really it's
getting really dark I'm getting scared
actually
you never know what kind of beasts lair
are in these realms okay Oh [ __ ] sake
oh [ __ ] sake oh [ __ ] sake
now now yeah aah oh my god Bryce I'm I'm
actually [ __ ] scared what the hell
don't come near me
I may have murdered all your family for
members but that doesn't mean we can't
get along I'm gonna make a very serious
tumblr post about you home sweet home
isn't that right that's lit you up nice
lady [ __ ] there for you yeah but if I
dare you
let's have a dinner snack and then we
can go to sleep I suppose sorry Lizzie
yeah can't get me heads high it's your
fault for being delicious it's okay kids
I know I'm with arm now no you wouldn't
yes I am arm as the power of a lot of
things but I have the power love it I
thought we have something special well
so do I so do I bit arm just eat me and
get it over one let's go to sleep good
night Bruce I can't place the houseboat
anyway see I want to build a house but
but I can't place it anywhere it doesn't
doesn't work let's go with hand and if
he comes in handy and actually fine
Timmy I want to see if Tim is out there
so this is starfish how did you get here
please answer me that quest
do you get a meaty fish all right there
seems to be stuff down there let's oh
god I don't want to die um let's check
it out for farming helluva tada what I
landed in water what do you want from me
ice all right we're back I'm back home
all right bunny I don't know what your
survival tactic Ed's but so far it's not
working out breakfast is served
well someone didn't go to backpack
school cuz this is not how you backpack
stew
where are you going come back here
backpack don't think you can escape what
I never be it a stone oh my god
why should who should we throw it on
let's find someone this must be the
magical storm of backpack that have
heard about in the legends
this looks good yep we're getting there
they're gonna get me you stony
I like the little things that they make
ah that's nice as a dead baby fetus
uh-huh
and he's licking it uh-huh
and then we have Marcus here hello
Marcus Marcus like to take selfies and
then we have Lizzy
Lisa come back what are you doing are
you working with them where are you know
that son of a [ __ ] I knew it was up to
no good you know ma'am what the [ __ ] was
that
stop suiciding inside me stupid
god damn it makes me angry ah so what
are you supposed to be then I think this
plant is on mess what the hell are these
plants they don't look so good
what is this field what are they what
are they holding here I don't know it's
called in English put your hands up put
your hands up put your hands up home
sweet home alright press isn't that much
else we could do we built most of it we
explored most of it we have found a lot
of arms I know you brought us one or
that looks nice
I'm I don't even know hop hop hop well
yeah go ahead leave a like if you
enjoyed watching this episode I really
appreciate it and I will see you bros in
the next one stay awesome bros love you